Speaker 1: My friends, they aren't even pretending
anymore that they don't want more violence.
They're threatening it openly. They're telling us,
you know, we might have to do more violent stuff.
I'm about to play VIDEO for you of former Trump
strategist and former Breitbart propagandist
Steve Bannon. Steve Bannon says We aren't
going to have 4000 shock troops ready to go.
We're going to have 20000 shock troops ready to
go so that we can take control of this country.
They aren't even hiding it anymore. Let's
take a look at the video. This is from
the Steve Bannon's program, The War Room
on Real America's Voice. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: The opposition, particularly the
opposition elite and all their side boys,
everything a Silicon Valley media. It's not a big
part of the population, and they understand that
they understand it. The thing they fear is
the righteous indignation of the working class
in this country. And now they're saying
it, and that's why they're in meltdown.
The story I gave this talk to these appointees
and here's what I said. We're winning big in
2022. We're going to win big in 2024. We need to
get ready now. Right? We control this country.
We've got to start acting like it. And when
we're going to act like it, we're not going to
have 4000 ready to go. We're going to have 20000
ready to go and we're going to pick the 4000 best
and the most ready in every single department.
And that's when we really start to deconstruct
the administrative state that's talking of
see if they always try to destroy it. No, no,
no, no, no. We're trying to get an FDA working
Speaker 1: shock troops on standby. We control
this country. We have to start acting
like it. And as Zach Patricio reported,
Joe Ben, Steve Bannon continued by talking
about the importance of spiritual warfare
to his audience to defeat the enemy. This is
exactly what the FBI should be investigating this.
This is exactly the type of thing that will rile
people up and get them ready to do horrible things
again. He's essentially calling for A.. So,
I mean, it is militia, even the right word.
He's calling for people to be on standby to
forcibly take slash remain in power. Now I do want
to sort of turn this around and take that, take
it as an opportunity to make a different point.
If there aren't more, see if there aren't more
and more serious consequences for the Jan. six
rioters that will also implicitly encourage
them to try again and to go crazier.
This guy was the chief strategist for
the president of the United States.
This is not ending any time soon. It's been
less than a year since Trump helped by senators,
members of Congress, the MAGA people, people like
Steve Bannon. They encouraged, they incited. They
pushed for an attempt to try to take the election
from the guy who actually won it. Who is Joe Biden
now? Some of the dupes, some of the
patsies, that's really what they are.
They've faced repercussions to some degree. A
couple have been sentenced somewhere in the middle
of trials. We talked earlier about the mother and
son who were arrested, but none of the people who
instigated it in Congress has lost the seat. Now
we haven't had elections yet. I understand that
we'll see if they lose seats. But the point
is it's not clear whether they will really
have and suffer electoral consequences for their
inciting for the fomenting of what happened on
Jan. six. So, you know, we saw the lone wolf
recently who tried to burn down a democratic
office in Texas. Things like that, as long as the
right continues to at a at a structural level,
push this type of violent rhetoric. They're
going to continue through this kind of
stochastic terrorism that we've talked about
before creating these individual incidents.
The individuals may face consequences. Some
may not so may plead out. We don't know yet,
but are they really lone wolves when you have
this entire Partizan apparatus, right wing media
apparatus, a strong contingent of Republicans in
the House and Senate when they're encouraging it?
Are they really even lone wolves anymore, even
if the physical act is one they carry out by
themselves? As far as we know, there's this
entire apparatus kind of vaguely encouraging
this behavior, if not specifically. Now some
are asking how is what Steve Bannon is saying,
not treasonous. Treason is a sort of specific
in terms of its legal definition. Article three,
Section three of the Constitution, which says
treason against the U.S. shall consist only in
levying war against them or in adhering
to their enemies, giving them aid and
comfort. The key is that treason means going
against the U.S. and Americans as a whole.
This is all kind of tinged enough about going
against a political party and a movement
that it's probably not sufficient to meet
the definition of treason. It's more like a
seditious conspiracy to overthrow the the
particular government that there is or something
like that. But it doesn't make it any more morally
acceptable. Let's make that completely clear. So
we're going to see more of this action in real
life because we're continuing to see more of
the rhetoric on right wing media. And, you know,
going back to my earlier segment on Russell Brand
without straight up being anti-vax and
Russell Brand probably isn't anti-vax. He has
kind of threaded a line that is asking
the right questions, as they love to say,
to push people to become anti-vax on their own.
If they're not already and if and if they
are already, you just kind of encourages them
and ingrained them in those beliefs. This
is very similar with what we're seeing with
Tucker. Calling about a real insurrection might
be warranted. Steve Bannon talking about 20000
shock troops and the like. This is real stuff,
and it has real consequences in the real world